a young woman seeks revenge for the
death of her father and from a young age
is trained to be a criminal
however she ends up working in an agency
that promises her a normal life although
that promise will be crushed on her
wedding day
today on similar recapped i'll show you
the villainous
the film begins with a person whose face
we do not see
this person confronts several men inside
a building who are part of a criminal
organization the stranger kills many men
and then reaches the top floor of the
building where the mafia boss is found
along with several guards taking care of
him the person fights against all these
men and during the fight we finally get
a face reveal and find out that the
stranger is a woman with short hair the
woman named sukhi
manages to defeat the man and
immediately approaches the boss she ties
a rope around his neck and then she
takes the other end of the rope and
jumps out of a window killing the man
tsuki lets go of the rope and falls to
the ground where suddenly the police
appear to arrest her later we see some
people in an office watching the videos
recorded by security cameras of the
building they see how sookie defeated
the entire criminal organization which
they had been looking for people also
seen the cameras how another person took
advantage of the entire conflict by
entering the building and stealing drugs
but they did not know who it is because
he was wearing a mask these people
discuss what to do with suekee since
they know that she's dangerous and at
that moment a woman says that she could
be very valuable because her great
ability to fight later we see suki in a
white room she gets up for a moment but
she starts to breathe in a gas and ends
up fainting after a few seconds suki
opens her eyes from time to time and in
one of those moments she sees how she's
in an operating room
some people are doing surgery on her
face as if they were changing her
features
a few days later we see that suki is in
the room again but this time she's
eating then the gas reappears and tsuki
falls asleep immediately at that moment
we see a scene from the past when tsuki
was training with other men to hold her
breath and we can see that she's very
good at it because she lasted six
minutes without breathing in the present
so ben wait for a few minutes and then
enter suki's room to take her away
but she wasn't really passed out she
only pretended and held her breath
suki escapes from the room and then runs
into several quiet girls who are doing
different activities such as dancing
cooking or acting suki manages to go to
the terrace but just when she was going
to escape she shot and falls to the
ground all of this is caught on camera
and there are men watching everything
that happens
these men say that suki will be assigned
to one of them and whoever can make her
fall in love will get a promotion
later suki is in a room with a lady
who's the head of an agency the woman
tells sukee that she's pregnant
and that she has to sign a contract if
she wants to keep her and her baby's
lives safe she also tells her that she
has to live in that place for 10 years
and obey
and after that time she'll be free suhi
accepts for the sake of her baby and
stays there
where she has a normal life since she
cooks and has recreational facilities
but she also trains to be a better
fighter after a while suki has her baby
a girl and we see that they already know
which band she's going to be assigned to
so this man whose name is
shows a lot of interest in her then we
see a bit of suki's past and it seems
that her father was killed and she
wanted revenge but she never managed to
do it in the present tsuki trains for
several years while her daughter grows
up after a while the boss tells her that
she has her first mission to kill a man
tsuki accepts and goes to the man's
house ending his life
however at that moment she sees that the
man's daughter has just witnessed
everything so tsuki remembers the time
when she also saw her dad getting killed
and can't remember who did it in the
present the guards find out what's
happening so she quickly leaves the
house and tries to escape on a
motorcycle but the guards follow her
she drives to the streets defeating a
few guards on the road however she gets
cornered so she ends up escaping by
throwing herself into the sea a few days
later as sookie managed to do the
mission successfully they tell her that
they will be setting her free that
she'll be able to live a normal life in
a normal house the boss takes suki and
her daughter to a house in the city and
gives them new names suki moves to her
new home and there she runs into hyun
soo the man to whom she was assigned and
realized that this man has just moved
into the apartment next door
so now they'll be neighbors
but this is all part of the plan to make
suki fall in love hyun soo begins to get
closer to suki and her daughter little
by little managing to win her heart in
another scene from her past we see that
suki used to work in a criminal
organization because when her father
died she was kidnapped
the mafia boss saved her and from that
moment on she began to train and work
for him we also realized that suki ended
up falling in love with her boss and
they got married but right on their
honeymoon the boss had to leave suki
alone in a motel room
after a few hours suki was told that her
boss now her husband had been killed by
the same man who killed her father then
suki wanted revenge more than ever so
she went to kill the murderer which was
the mafia boss that we saw at the
beginning of the movie in the present
suki has a date with hyun soo then they
go home and make out but suddenly suki's
boss calls her telling her that she has
another mission
suzuki asks the man to stay and look
after her daughter while she goes out
for a bit suki goes to location of the
mission where she sees a friend she met
at the agency the friend tells her that
they complete that mission they will let
her be free as well then the two proceed
to do the mission which is to obtain
information from some men
however something goes wrong and they're
caught so a fight begins and suki's
friend ends up dying
later tsuki delivers the information to
her boss and goes home very sad the next
day suki asks yun-soo to marry her
because if something happens her
daughter can stay with him then suki
mentions the wedding to her boss and the
boss accepts it and even offers to
organize the event the day of the
wedding suki receives a call from her
boss who tells her that she has a
mission to assassinate someone with a
sniper rifle
suki goes to the bathroom wearing her
wedding dress and takes the gun they
prepared for aiming from one of the
windows
however just when she was going to shoot
she realizes that the target is her
ex-husband whose name is joong song suki
is so shocked that this man is still
alive that she ends up missing the shot
then she puts down the gun and erases
all the evidence before she continues
with her wedding tsuki ends up marrying
hyun soo and at the end of their wedding
she wonders how her ex-husband is still
alive she deduces that it was all a hoax
and that he wanted to get rid of her and
that's why he faked his death sending
her to the building to fight the
criminal organization that night we see
the jung song the man who was supposedly
dead investigates who tried to kill him
and discovers that it was
although at first does not recognize her
since they changed her face he ends up
realizing that it was her then suki
finds out that another girl will soon be
sent to kill her ex-husband
and decides not to do anything a few
days later suki receives some flowers
with a note and a usb drive
she examines the contents of the memory
card privately finding a recording in
which hyun-soo her current husband says
it is a member of the agency just like
her
tsuki realizes that this man fooled her
that he only fell in love with her work
and also deduces that the one who sent
her the video was her ex-husband so she
returns the favor by notifying him that
they're going to try again to kill him
then joon song manages to avoid being
killed and captures the girl who was
going after him meanwhile suki's boss
goes to look for and captures her in
order to exchange hostages with jung
song
later suki and her boss are on their way
to the exchange point when suddenly
they're cornered by some men
these men eliminate all the guards but
the boss manages to escape suki removes
her handcuffs and realizes that jung
song her ex-husband rescued her
sookie asks him to go pick up her
daughter to which joong song agrees but
just when suki was about to go up to the
apartment she sees hyun soo and her
daughter hurtled out of the window by an
explosion they fall to the ground dead
suki gets very angry and goes to her
boss's office to claim her because she
thinks she is the one who had her family
killed
however the boss tells her that it
wasn't her and shows her recordings of
the department so she can see the truth
we see that when hyun-soo arrived at the
apartment with a girl he was kidnapped
by jung song's men
after a few minutes jung-soo had the
opportunity to talk to jung-song and
told him that the girl is his daughter
since was pregnant before she came to
the agency but even though he knew that
the girl could be his daughter jung song
asked junsu to kill her and in exchange
he would spare his life
hyunsoo did not accept the deal and
tried to fight the men
but he couldn't beat them
then jung song's men rigged the bomb
inside the apartment they monitored
everything and when they saw suki
arriving detonated the bomb once
finished watching the recording suki
gets very angry and shoots wildly the
boss tells her that hewn sue did not
make her fall in love just because of
work but that he actually really loved
her tsuki decides to take revenge
against her ex-husband and goes to look
for him
when she finds him she complains about
what he did to her family and jung-song
replies that he not only killed them but
that he's also the murderer of her
father when she hears this suki gets
even angrier and starts fighting jung
song after a lot of fighting jung song
decides to escape at a bus with this
whole gang but tsuki takes a car and
follows them she manages to catch up
with him and get on the bus then she
starts fighting the gang until only she
jung song and the driver are left
tsuki and jung song have another fight
and just when it looked like junson was
going to win tsuki manages to move the
steering wheel making the bus flip
everyone is injured by the impact but
tsuki manages to stand
she approaches jung song and he asks her
to kill him saying that nothing matters
anymore but then after she kills him
she'll regret it suki ends his life and
at that moment the police arrive to
arrest her again just like at the
beginning of the movie the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
recaps of the best drama in action
movies
thanks for watching